what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to
rich cooper clips how to tell if you're
a simp so i've said this before and i'll
say it again
the man of sphere calls everyone a symp
they literally call everyone a sims
so i'm really curious
to see what the simp test is i'm
reacting to this live i've never seen
this before
i'm just genuinely curious
here's a bit of a simp test for you all
right
because you know some guys are going how
do i know i'm sipping when do i know
that i'm sipping like how do i stop
we'll get to the solution in a minute
but how do i know that i'm a simp
all right well you can start by
constantly trying to impress women okay
are you constantly trying to impress
women
right are you constantly you know
telling them that they're beautiful
on social media are you constantly
dropping hearts and dm'ing them
whenever they post a picture somebody
that um
i agree with this 100 i agree with this
you're following because you're a big
fan
right are you ask yourself that question
i don't follow any women on any of my
social media i don't look like there's
lots of beautiful women out there that i
can look at and admire of course because
beauty is
something that you're going to just
check out right but i don't follow them
because i don't want to get distracted
out you know for my purpose i know what
i'm doing
i don't need to look at you know boobs
and butt all day long
i'm not a dork i got stuff to do right
that is something you got to ask
yourself are you and even what he just
said
right there i i don't got to look at
boobs and butt all day
long i got stuff to do that's a very
attractive like
phrase because he's saying your looks
they can't impress me
you have to have more constantly trying
to impress women
showering women with compliments and
money
okay the money is a big part of this
simp economy today
because a lot of these thirst traps out
there
on the different platforms as a matter
if it's twitch only fans instagram
instagram snapchat snap instagram
only fan mix it up whatever comes next
a lot of you guys are throwing loads of
money at these women
loads of money cam girls like
these women couldn't care
let me put it to you this way if she was
walking down the street with a glass of
water in her hand
and you were on fire she'd probably keep
walking while drinking the glass of
water
okay there's no like you're not going to
get any benefit out of
throwing my cousin who does only fans
has literally said that she would never
date any of the guys
that send her money and she does not
care about them money
at a woman she's got to have genuine
burning desire for you can't
buy your way into her heart you can
buy your way into her heart if you got
loads of money
i've seen some rich nerds i've
shared the stereo this story before
there was a little danny devito looking
dude that owned three of the buildings
um back in the 90s when i was working
down at young and shepherd
and he kept a whole like wall full of
exotic cars down there
different girl every time i saw him
different hot girl every time
you know every time i saw him little
danny devito looking dude
well that amount of money will get you
the girls but the amount of money that
most sims throw at the girls
it's nothing it just it just piles in
it's like 10 bucks from this guy
10 bucks from this and that's the thing
a quality girl isn't gonna care about
your money
like she's not gonna stay just for your
money you do not want a girl
that is gonna leave you the second [ __ ]
gets hard you do not want that
so yeah i could i could see what he's
saying with that this guy
oh he made a 24 donation oh this guy's a
super
fan he paid a 100 500 whatever it
doesn't even matter
she she just looks at you guys as
paychecks
you're basically tax cattle
are you white knighting are you
constantly trying to
swoop in to protect the honor of milady
are you
white knights are the worst i got to
tell you white knights simps
simply white knights they're brutal most
of them
most of them come from a weak household
okay where
father was non-existent or he was just a
[ __ ]
and mom just you know molded him into
some
weak pathetic beta male she basically
molded him into what the father never
was
because she wanted that in her life
but at the end of the day she doesn't
want to sleep with that
little boy you know she sends that
little boy off in the world calls him a
man
but he's still a little boy in his head
thinking that if he's bending the knee
and always nice and
doing the dishes you know we we have
this
epidemic now of chore play with married
couples
and if you're not familiar with what
chore play is it's basically where
husbands are doing chores around the
house that would conventionally be done
by his wife in order to get intimacy
so he's trying to exchange doing the
dishes
uh taking care of the kids to ex okay i
don't
think you should be with a girl that
withholds sex in order to get things um
i don't want to completely draw
conclusions because i do think that men
overestimate me how much it takes for a
woman to get turned on so there are
times when
if you're irritating your girlfriend
all day because you're just watching her
do things and you're not being helpful
and then you want to have sex with her
later like she might not be in the mood
but
um i don't
necessarily think
i'm trying to phrase this correctly
i don't think that's always like women
just withholding sex but if you're the
girl that says like you cannot
have sex until you do this run like run
that is not a good girl that is not
someone you want to be with
extracurriculars
cover you know cut the grass put away
the dishes hang the shelves
he's trying to exchange all of that for
a little bit
of starfish intimacy in the bedroom
once every couple weeks if he's lucky
once every couple weeks
god damn score plays that's simping type
of behavior that's that's
it's silly right you're trying to
married life it's like oh no
negotiate desire with a woman i will do
all of these things for you
because we are equals and you will want
to enthusiastically jump my bones
this is the thinking they have going
through their heads that's not how it
goes down
women need to have genuine burning
desire for you
i think it's the second or third chapter
of my book i spent a lot of time putting
that information together for you
and giving you a way to assess it
because it's important i kind of want to
read the book
if somebody sends this book to me i will
read it and do a video important to
understand what it looks like
and why you should always seek to get it
from women
if you're not getting it you're wasting
your time see i don't like that
i do not like that at all because
like guys as an adult you don't think
that there's some value in getting to
know somebody before you sleep with them
and not everything is a
exchange of goods and services it's
human relationships
so honestly i wouldn't want to be with a
guy
that looks at relationships as an
exchange of goods and services
because there's more to a relationship
than just sex
like are your values the same do you
have common interests
um are there things that you guys like
to do together lifestyle work ethic
um and on and not just like what women
look for from men but what men
look for from women is she fit is she
friendly is she feminine
um that takes time to figure out
so i don't know my two cents a scale of
one to ten
nine and ten would be genuine burning
desire seven eight would be indifferent
she kind of likes you but she's not sure
maybe she needs to [ __ ] test you a
little bit to see if you really are the
man that she thinks that you might be
and then six to one the tractor
she could not care if you stop breathing
if you didn't get up in the morning
you are invisible to her and almost
all the simping behavior goes to women
that are completely oblivious to who you
are
you're invisible to them they don't yeah
okay yeah
care
sim test getting little to zero success
with women
what does that mean i mean if you want
to go out with a girl
you'll want to be intimate with her you
want to
have a good time with her are you
getting success with that or not
because if you're not you're probably
sinking too much
other stuff that ties into that like
texting back way too fast and
persistently and good morning and good
night every freaking day
you know multiple days straight several
times in a row there is this one
um i personally don't like texting i
much prefer a phone call
i'm just holding a conversation over
text is so
i just don't like it screenshot i had i
think i shared it on an instagram story
at one point
and it was like this this guy just kept
going down it's like
day number 13 of asking you to be my
girlfriend day number 14 of asking you
my girlfriend
it's like every day this dude would send
a text message to this chick
and i got this screen capture i don't
know who sent it to me but it's like
every single day with a new time date
stamp dude's like
day number 16 i'm asking you to be my
girlfriend day number 17
it just kept going on and on and on
simping right
texting back too persistently too fast
too enthusiastically
when she's got no desire for you you
know what i'm saying
um let me get these supers right here
hold on
one man's chorus rich don't you think
toxic masculinity is kind of a hoax
it doesn't exist outside of website
headlines it is not enforced on men
masculinity is weapons i did think about
that
is there any part of masculinity that's
toxic
i'm definitely not team toxic
masculinity for everything but i'm
genuinely thinking if there's anything
about masculinity that i think is super
toxic um nothing that comes straight to
my head except
maybe that i don't think men always feel
like they can talk about their feelings
um with women and to each other and i
know it's a double-edged
sword because i know women do lose
attraction to men
if they're too emotional so obviously
there's a limit
but the male suicide rate i believe is
much higher than women
so just like my thought process but i'm
curious to see what he says
nice against men real men do x
um is it a hoax yeah all that it is
is just anything that the feminine
imperative doesn't like that doesn't
serve it
okay um we're not making enough money we
don't have enough days off we should
have more
free insert whatever it is and
some guy or a group of men get in the
way of that
they'll just throw that's toxic
masculinity on that
right there's no such thing there's just
masculinity
okay when there's a war when the floods
come
when there's a hurricane when there's a
tornado and they gotta call in the
national guard to come and fix [ __ ]
when the two planes slammed into the
twin towers
okay 20 odd years ago and they came
and they were about to come crumbling
down who was running up into those
buildings
men firefighters police officers it was
men that were running up those stairs to
try to save
everybody up there screaming not being
able to find a way out and they call
that toxic masculinity today
it's just conventional masculinity
because again like i said
anytime the feminine imperative a female
first primary social order doesn't get
what it wants from men
then they start slapping labels on it to
try to insult and degrade
and i could definitely see that the
interesting thing i noticed at my
parents on lake house this weekend so
my dad bought a water slide from a water
park and then he like put it
like i'm talking like an industrial
giant water slide and he literally built
it so it goes into the river
and i'm not even gonna lie it is not the
safest thing in the world at all
and so there's a tendency for the women
to stay away from it
and the men to just go down it even
though they might get hurt so i've
always noticed
that the men when we're at our river
house will be like on the jet skis
boating all the stuff tubing
and the women will be talking on the
porch diminish what it is that you're
doing
and yeah it's a form of weaponization
yeah i would agree with that
he didn't completely clarify what
something was to me
um i mean i definitely agree
that the like the simply the commenting
behavior day 14 of asking
you to be my girlfriend that is a
hundred percent behavior i agree with
that
um i think if you're negotiating with
your wife
for sex i mean it's all it's all
situational because
then my mind obviously goes to
situations where
that would make sense um like if she
just had a baby
or something but if your wife's not
sleeping with you i
and you're negotiating by like trying to
do chores to get sex
um that seems like a very sad way to
live so that does sound simply to me
but they called guys like jeff bezos
samp
and i don't really see it with him so
i don't know i get a little confused in
the manuscript because they call so many
people a sim but let me know in the
comments
what you guys think is simp behavior do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell and i will
talk to you guys next time